let me let me let me know if you guys
agree or disagree with this
hypothesis the problem with anti-fascism
is that we live in a
military-industrial complex system that
is inherently fascist
our clothing is made in sweatshops for
the most part
fat with like corporate government
fascism it's more like it's corporate
government
it's it's authoritarian corporatism
militaristic it's like stuff is done by
force
so it's it feels like we we're
supporting a fascist not a dictatorship
it's not
it's a militaristic i hate i hate the
united states as a military
fascist is a very specific thing like
it's a very specific
brand of authoritarianism that comes
from world war ii everyone says
fascist what they really mean is
authoritarian okay so so what happens is
then you get people arguing about state
control versus like
you know ethnonationalism and what is
really fascinating like i don't care
dude
i'm talking about authoritarian
dictatorships so are these
antifa actually just anti-authoritarian
no
they're pro-authoritarian pro-pro
they're they're communist extremists
they
want the power this is what i really
really can't stand
you have to see the political compass
memes you guys yeah where it's like
they always put antifa in the bottom
left left libertarian
no anarchists have the non-aggression
principle
is that that's what it's right not
non-action principle yeah well it's
mostly a right-wing anarchist thing
which
i i don't even know what that means
right-wing cap and libertarian yeah not
an arc
communist but the general idea should be
a part of anyone who doesn't believe
authority is proper so
a real anarchist and and you'll you'll
hear this from actual leftists who
actually know they're talking about
because like i think left anarchists the
real ones
you'd totally love to hang out with them
you know why they're sitting around
smoking weed and like eating watermelon
yeah but they let chaos happen no they
don't that's not like whatever
it is in their house that's just work
well that's not true i used to live with
it
that's not anarchist then you didn't you
lived with nihilists
no they just didn't have any rules
that's not anarchy
anarchy means without authority true
anarchists
it means you sit in a circle and you all
talk until you agree it's damn near
impossible to do at scale
but if you've got a group of five people
you can have an anarchic system where
you're like no
no one person is the authority well you
could also have a group of anarchists
where you all fight each other until one
person survives
that's not like real anarchy
that's just so the actual idea
of anarchy it means and without archy
authority that's what it means
and so and anna so this is really funny
i was watching i was just watching the
uh movie stranger than fiction have you
guys ever seen that it's actually really
fun it's will ferrell and like he's
walking on the street and then all of a
sudden he hears a narrator
narrating his life and then like one day
she's like diddle
little did harold know he was going to
die and then he's like wait what who
said that you know
but anyway he's a tax auditor and he's
talking to this leftist and he asks her
are you part of an anarchist group and
she goes anarchists have groups
and it was um what's what's her name
maggie gyllenhaal and he's like i
don't know and she's like that would
defeat the purpose like no it wouldn't
anarchist means without authority you
can have a group of people where no one
person has authority
and they all sit in big circles and they
sing kumbayan ask each other what each
other wants to do until everyone comes
into agreement
it doesn't work at scale like you can't
even do it 10 people you know you can do
with like three
or four so it's really like a pipe dream
to say that the left
libertarian spectrum like antifa are
anti-authoritarian
is like an outright lie the people that
are going around smashing things
and demanding their will be done is the
definition of authoritarian
absolute they think they have authority
over
you to force you to do what they want
and they will use physical force against
you to get what they want
that's authoritarianism just because
they're not
in the most powerful group so imagine
this way
if a group of 100 people showed up and
said
raise our flag or we will murder your
family
is that authoritarian yes it doesn't
matter if they're part of the state or a
gang
because the only difference between that
concept they try and lie about
is like they don't have the full power
of government yet
so there so imagine what antifa would do
if they actually gained control of a
government
how how would you explain like a um an
antarctic is it antarctic
antarctic an antarctic group that want
if
if like a antarctic group something if
antifa were antarctic how would they be
behaving differently
they wouldn't be violent well you could
have violent anarchy
it's it no that that impli it's
oxymoronic
the idea that you have the sole
authority to cause harm to another
person is not without authority it is
with authority
yeah but i mean doing something doesn't
mean that you're authoritarian
so i guess theoretically you could have
no authority and no goals and no
purpose so you just want to burn it all
so they have a goal and a purpose
they just wanted to destroy it that
would be more nihilism i think
and i think that's still an exertion of
your authority over someone else
i think you're being too liberal with
the definition of authority if you
think you can unilaterally decide to
alter someone else's existence
like i don't make decisions for them i
don't see
antifa trying to implement anything i
just see them trying to break the system
well antifa are our revolutionary
communists
that the antifa literally comes from
world war ii germany it was the it was
the militant wing of the communist party
and anti-fascism doesn't mean
anti-authoritarian they're
pro-authoritarian they were
pro-communist party
the people flying their flag want
authoritarianism they want to tell
people what to do
because they think the stupid people and
their farting cows are destroying the
planet
so anti-fascists were an actual party
of the communist a part of the
communists authoritarian communists but
this
uh anti-fascist group is not that
it's a different same flag
but like you say you can call yourself
the nice guys and go around and beat
people and be like
why would you beat down on the nice guys
they're flying the symbols in the flag
right but they're different
functions that's like saying neo-nazis
aren't really nazis they're
that's why they're called new nazis
they're not sure then we'll call them
antifa yeah they're so it's not
necessarily the same authoritarian group
that the communists had
it's basically thing i don't but i don't
i don't agree with that i think they
have the same name
in the same flag but they're they're not
authoritarian they're not anarchists
that's just they're not anarchists man
how would you describe them cassandra
um i think that they're authoritarian
i don't know if i would i mean i don't
know
you guys both have some valid points i
think that they're terrifying
and that's basically it i think that
they believe that they're morally right
and their conscience is telling them
that they're doing the right thing by
being
ultra authoritarian and imposing their
will on people and i think that that's
the most dangerous kind of person it's
the same thing that you see with like
isis
they think that they're committing acts
of terror and authoritarianism um
for the greater good it's the same thing
and i just think that they're
if if you take antifa and you give them
positions of power in the government
they will all agree on what they want to
do next
they bring out guillotines in front of
people's homes they are acting in
concert
they know what their ideology is they
know what they want
and they will use violence to get it cnn
around this really funny piece antifa
seeking peace through violence
yeah and they changed the title after
they got called out for it they are
violent authoritarians
i guess you could it's a weird argument
to make
that you have violent
anti-authoritarians because
i guess the joker you could argue you
know because he
he had no real goal in in destroying
your life
but i personally feel like if i say to
you
i'm going to cause you harm i am making
a decision about what i want you to
experience and do and that is me
asserting my will over yours but it
would be why were you doing if you were
doing it so that you could get
the money and make me your slave then
you'd be authoritarian but if you were
doing it so
to watch me die then you wouldn't be i
disagree it's me saying my will over
yours
imposing your will is not um well i mean
you're always imposing your will though
no we we work in a constitutional
republic with democratically elected
leaders
so we do exert our will but it's through
cooperation and through laws
right so so their authority exists like
our system isn't anarchic we live in a
country that
is uh uh slightly more
it's we live in a rather centrist
society we're not too authoritarian we
kind of are in a lot of ways
and we're not completely libertarian but
we have certain freedoms in certain
areas and we're not super left we're not
super right
in terms of economics we're a mixed
economy and it's it's fairly balanced
it's fairly balanced i can say i want to
elect this person and i can exert my
will and others can challenge that but
we don't beat each other to death
and i don't go to someone and steal
their money take their assets from them
so they can't compete
they're allowed to compete fairly and
equal footing because i don't have
power over them in a certain capacity so
exerting your will
without violence is you would consider
not authoritarian but not
through violence is authoritarian no if
i went to you and said i will
blood you know i will i will uh publish
embarrassing photos about your
significant other it's just exerting if
some kind of
force coercive manipulative or physical
force against a person to
to subjugate their will then at that
point i wonder why you're doing it i
think whether or not it's authoritarian
comes down to why you're doing it
does it matter the joker he wasn't like
i agree with you i don't think he was
authoritarian i think he was just
anarch anarchic he was crazy the new
joker was based on bernie goetz
which is like a really famous case that
kind of applies i've been thinking about
it a lot with kyle rittenhouse
but the person that they based it off
was he was just sick of crime
and he wanted to stand up to people
harassing him on the subway and
he ended up shooting people oh the new
joker
yeah the movie that was a great movie
but yeah the nra like took up his case
back in the 90s and um
vigilantism yeah so the way i see it is
for one yeah there's there's nuance in
the discussion but if you have a group
of people who
agree on their ideology um particularly
that they're all racist
so they they all are racist these these
antifa people are identitarian
they believe freaky weird things about
race
and they want racialized law they go
around saying how do we get that
we beat people until they submit that's
authoritarianism
because they're trying to impose this
critical race it's not even about impose
they're enforcing their will through
through through by by subjugating you if
you had a government
that said do it or else and they went
around telling people no more speaking
out against us it's authoritarianism
just because they're not as big as a
government doesn't mean they're not
authoritarian
so you like i was talking to i was
actually talking to an antifa guy in
berkeley a couple years ago
and i explained to him when he when he
was talking to me about you know look
these right-wing groups they come here
and they're fascists
so we got to fight back and i was like
come on man that little old lady
like one of you guys threw a m80 at that
old woman over there and he's like
well like you know she shouldn't be with
the fascists i'm like she didn't come
with fascists she just showed up with a
trump flag and then other people showed
up
and he was like well i think these
people need to understand that we're
like what we're doing is better and i
was like so you're an authoritarian
and he goes dude you can't be an
authoritarian okay
because that's like a government and i
was like and socialism is a government
are you saying you can't be a socialist
and he was like wait i mean thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you